milk by definition is a dairy product
that is secreted by mammals so milk is a
mammal's secretions
it should say that on the damn Carton
and if what you're drinking is not
secreted from a mammal then it's not
milk cashew milk coconut milk Walnut
milk that's like nut juice
flax milk and vegan chocolate chip
cookie
I don't know what flax is either can
someone tell me what flax is
you plant flax seed in the ground what
do you get
so you just get more seeds it just it
just makes seeds erupt out of the ground
[Music]
oh my God that's terrible that is really
really bad there's no way anyone chooses
to drink this what and what why would
you do that to yourself